vingt dernières secondes fatales l'ex
berruyère elodie godin égalise pour
montpellier en blanc à 60 par tous les
tangos ont la main et céline dumerc la
capitaine incontournable rac le cercle
fatigués par leur titre de championnes
de france décrochée au forceps quatre
jours plus tôt bon je vais disputer la
prolongation de tre je pense qu'on a pas
on n'a pas toujours été carrée
d'endroits là dans les instructions
ça se paie cash en fin de saison comme
ça quand à l'apathie quand en face on a
une très bonne équipe de montpellier cas
très envie de gagner en plus de ça qui a
pu se reposer un petit peu voilà ça se
paye cash
et pourtant quand le collectif
verrouillé fait tourner en début de
partie il semble intouchable en route
pour le doublé championnat-coupe 2015
demi-finaliste en championnat cette
saison
les héraultaises s'accroche à la pause
c'est bourges qui est devant 34 31
mais les montpelliéraines ont de la
ressource et une fraîcheur qui manquent
à bourges
près de 60 % de réussite à trois points
elle domine de troisième quart temps je
passe devant tu passes devant le
quatrième quart temps et a le temps
bourges va compenser son manque de
lucidité par l'arm le métier et un brin
de talent mais ce ne sera pas suffisant
on avait plus de temps calme pour
préparer le match et ça c'est un plus
quand même j'ai pourrir alors finalement
c'est bon jusqu'à faire du bail et on a
travaillé idiot pour gagner ce match
mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu plus de temps
pour préparer ce match par rapport à
bourges et ça c'est un gros plus est
gros moins pour bourges qui s'effondre
en prolongation 76-69 score final
montpellier a mérité cette coupe de
france une nouvelle ère va s'ouvrir pour
le club berruyer millésime 2015 2016
c'est difficile de budgétiser pour l'an
prochain parce que on a un nouveau volet
sport on sait pas exactement où on va
donc on va quand même rester prudent
pour une première année après en
fonction de ce qu'on va faire pendant
l'intersaison on investira sur la
seconde solide aux avant postes
demeurent la devise du club berruyer
depuis 20 ans avec un certain succès
malgré cette finale perdue